place à présent à notre focus du jour on
va partir en ukraine dans les ruines
dire pini repine ville de la banlieue de
kiev où près de 300 civils ont perdu la
vie au début de la guerre un mois après
le retrait russe vous allez voir que les
habitants tente peu à peu de reprendre
une vie normale c'est un reportage signé
de nos envoyés spéciaux bastien renault
et nadia massy et ride à vous aider
gare centrale de kiev 7 heures du matin
vitaly rentrer chez lui cinq semaines
après la fuite de l'armée russe
sa ville est désormais un symbole des
destructions infligées par moscou
[Musique]
je voudrais revenir à irvine mais j'ai
peur de découvrir que mes amis ou mes
proches ou mes voisins ont été torturées
et assassinées par les russes
aujourd'hui c'est une ville fantôme
quand vitaly a fui les explosions ont
résonné dans tout le quartier
de cela plus de
moi ce serait un
jour je fumais une cigarette avec un ami
ici nous avons entendu le sifflement
d'un obus tiré par un mortier et des
explosions il ya eu trois grosses
explosions elle aurait pu tout détruire
et nous avons passé une nuit terrible
les russes ont piégé de nombreuses
maisons avant leur retraite mais les
voisins de vittel ils ont rassuré son
appartement n'a pas été visité
elle est bien barbarie ce cas nous
rentrons à la maison
mon appartement est vraiment sans dessus
dessous
nous avions recouvert les fenêtres pour
éviter que les vitres n'explose et ne
tombe sur le sol
je dois tout nettoyer
je suis tellement content d'avoir un
endroit hors venir
[Musique]
avant la guerre soit 110 mille personnes
vivaient tahir pin
la plupart ont fui
beaucoup n'ont plus d'endroit où devenir
une grande partie des habitations est
détruite
je suis revenu le 15 avril quand je suis
entré dans mon appartement j'ai vu que
tout était par terre
les portes étaient défoncés mon
appartement avait été pillé il était
jaloux de nos vies et ils le sont
toujours
il disait qu'il venait pour une
opération spéciale selon moi cette
opération spéciale consiste uniquement à
détruire notre mode de vie
dans leur résidence les missiles russes
ont presque tout détruit
les appartements qui n'ont pas explosé
ont brûlé
ces bénévoles viennent déplacés ce qui
peut encore être sauvé
les gens qui habitent ici vont déménager
dans un garage on récupère leurs meubles
ensuite le bâtiment sera démoli pour en
construire un autre
la mairie estime que 70% de la ville a
été touché par les combats
il faudra plus de 800 millions d'euros
pour la reconstruire
volodymyr nettoie la chambre de son fils
dans l'espoir qu'il revienne bientôt à
la maison
je n'ai pas vu de plus un mois
maintenant je pense qu'il va bien il
grandit petit à petit je lui parle tous
les jours
sa famille a fui au premier jour des
combats des balles ont traversé leur
appartement
j'ai changé la fenêtre mais je ne suis
pas sûr que les russes ne vont pas
revenir un jour donc j'ai décidé de les
recouvrir de film plastique au cas où
elle serait à nouveau cassé
alors que la guerre impact encore
durement le pays
la reconstruction commence 120
architectes ont été conviés par les
autorités ils doivent décider d'une
stratégie pour rebâtir pin
pour décider si les gens peuvent encore
vivre ici nous devons étudier l'ensemble
du bâtiment
comme cela nous saurons si un risque
qu'il s'effondre
si le résultat est positif
nous ferons ce que nous pourrons pour
renforcer la structure
il faudra du temps pour pierre pin
renaisse de ses cendres
plus de 1000 bâtiments d'habitation ont
été ravagés et beaucoup craignent ici
qu'en cas de nouvelles offensives les
destructions recommence
[Musique]
et puis tout de suite dans paris direct
le sport tout en images avec du football
pour commencer et notamment l'avant
dernière journée de ligue 1 regardez